Now, it's time to finish
creating our new view
by drawing its contents.
And, we do that within
our Custom View's onDraw method.
Now, the Android Canvas
is pretty standard
as far as canvas APIs go.
It uses the Painter's algorithm,
meaning that each new thing you paint
will cover anything beneath it.
The Canvas and Paint classes
offer a variety of brushes and helpers
to draw and fill lines,
boxes, circles, and text
with colors, patterns,
gradients, and images,
as well as offering the ability
to move, rotate, and scale the canvas
while you draw.
I could spend a lot of time here
detailing exactly how to use
each of these tools.
But there's nothing unique to Android,
and it's covered really well
on the documentation link below.
It is possible though to create
pretty advanced UIs this way.
For example, if we start by drawing
a circle and then add a second circle,
and then you just need to finish
drawing the rest of the compass.
Here's an example I prepared earlier.
The specifics of what you draw
are different for every view,
but one thing that is consistent,
is the resource constraint device
you're drawing on.
And that the onDraw method
will be called every time
the screen is refreshed,
potentially many times a second;
that means any object created here
within your onDraw method,
including things like paint objects,
will be created and destroyed
at an alarming frequency.
Object creation and destruction
can be expensive on Android;
potentially effecting
the smoothness of your UI
when garbage collection is initiated.
The solution?
Move the scope of any object
used within the onDraw loop,
into the class scope.
Go ahead and override
the onDraw method
within your new view
and draw the new control.
In fact, why not take this opportunity
to create a custom control
that can display the wind speed
and direction fused within sunshine.
Once you're done,
you can add it to your layer
using it it's full package name
and the class name in the XML like this.
Run it and then post a screenshot
of your new view into the forum.